dude so in tampa this weekend
at the end of one of my shows
this young girl yes i'm sorry
it's fine
i say this young girl but this is
actually like a grown-ass woman okay
she
she asked me
she says
are you gonna apologize for what you
said about the batman
oh god i think she's just she's being
funny oh yeah okay okay so it's like a
meme now at the show yeah yeah yeah and
then you've successfully distracted them
from the blowfish
oh no no and now there's new no you
still get that oh yeah so now it's gonna
be that on top of this yeah yeah oh
without fail you know it's always like
do the blowfish in the joker voice dude
it's not no it's always as it's always a
19 year old
frat kid
yo
it's always just that register of the
voice
yo can you do the fish noise
and they're always like in the back
they've just been waiting the whole show
so they're standing holding their third
pint of beer yeah yo cool set and
everything can you do the fish noise
but yeah so she says are you gonna
apologize and
i just lost it
i was like [ __ ]
and then
a group of people just start booing and
i just go no no no that's like
the most booze i've experienced like
genuine okay and i just lost it i'm like
[ __ ] you you just like that batman
because he's a [ __ ] loser that's your
dream just be a doomer and somehow end
up with a little woman like zoe kravitz
get the [ __ ] out of here that would
never happen in your real life i'm like
that movie is just redditers fantasizing
about their cat turning into a human and
then falling in love
i just i just went the cat yeah well
like like their cat you know with their
cat becoming a person yeah right and
that's catwoman yeah okay i see yeah
i was like there's no [ __ ] way you
get to be like an angsty teenager in the
darkness and then yeah is that is uh
is uh what the [ __ ] is his name edward
cullen yeah what the [ __ ] is it robert
pattinson is he kind of like a nice guy
in the movie
no he's like a emo teenager catwoman
he's like you're so you're so beautiful
yeah
i mean yeah he does like no you gotta he
does work harder than that yeah he does
keep his distance a little what the [ __ ]
women are all the same
i've been red pill [ __ ] oh my god dude
there's something like incel like oh
dude
in nolan's batman [ __ ] the joker
look at the dark knight
it went at the end spoiler alert for all
of you semen that haven't seen this
movie yet because it's too old for you
um all of you seaman yeah yeah anyone
younger than 18 i call them a seaman
they're just that's what you are
bro
uh
at the end you remember the ending right
batman has to choose between rachel and
harvey dent um
yeah vaguely
whatever yeah it's just kind of the
choice yeah and i haven't seen it yet so
thanks for ruining it
so there's this whole monologue that's
going on in the background because she
wrote this letter to batman because
there's a love triangle between bruce
wayne harvey dent and rachel
she [ __ ] writes this letter about how
she wasn't gonna choose him and then i
was dying laughing because after that
batman goes to save harvey and
officially it's so [ __ ] intel he like
reads the note and he's like [ __ ]
[ __ ] are all the same
he pulls up on harvey he's like save her
he's like no brother mgtow
men go their own way
[Laughter]
he just go smash some bruises
he goes up to the phone cause there's
like a phone connecting harvey and
rachel he just walks up to the intercom
and he's like yeah i bet you wish you
picked me huh women always go for the
[ __ ] yeah yeah
they never appreciate the nice guys
i was gonna let you ride in the
batmobile oh my god dude
i'm the one running around saving this
town and you want to go with this
[ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] you
kills harvey dennen lets her blow up
he just drives away
[Laughter]
you know [ __ ]
uh jt from chad and jt was pointing out
that the end of the the new batman was
so corny because he's like
everyone needs to put on the mask or
whatever because he's like in his second
year as batman and he's like trying to
figure out what his like i don't know
premises as the guy
he was like
he did all that badass [ __ ] and then it
was like weirdly like i don't know
positive okay it was kind of lame i
don't want to miss quote but he said
something that was super funny anyway
yeah all right we should probably stop
talking yeah i know i know i know i know
i don't know i know like it's been a lot
three weeks
it's been a great sketch that we made
it's fine dude yeah oh what do you guys
want nfts okay fine we can go back oh
yeah we can go back to crypto if that's
what you want no wait i do have to say
so
tampa this weekend
uh i went back to ebor were the chickens
oh good sorry i was gonna say this
before
can you do the blowfish noise in the
joker voice
no because it's just a gag
what do you mean it's just
yeah but could you do it a little bit
like
no okay
i can't i can't i can't i just
i can't
i'm sorry all right
my methods only go so far that's fair
yeah